there are other studies Michael that
show at an individual level for
individual when you're talking about the
effect on the epidemic or the pandemic
as a whole the data are less strong that
was Anthony fauci a big fan of mass
responding to the Cochran review which
found that wearing masks actually makes
little to no difference the Cochran
review it's more robust than others
because it only assesses studies that
use randomized controlled trials the
results are incontrovertible there's
very little evidence that mass are
making a significant difference when it
comes to catching covet this finding
really shouldn't surprise us don't take
it from me take it from fauci back in
March 2020. when you're in the middle of
an outbreak wearing a mask might make
people feel a little bit better and it
might even block a droplet but it's not
providing the Perfect protection that
people think that it is authorities
tempted to bring back Mass mandates
should listen to the fauci from back
then
[Music]